من جديد يؤكد رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني
السابق عمران خان ومن ورائه حزبه حركه
الانصاف اصراره على اجراء انتخابات
البرلمانيه مبكرا في البلاد في اغسطس
المقبل اخر وسائل الضغط التي مارسها خان
هي مسيره السبت التي نظمها انصاره في
مدينه البندي المحاديه للعاصمه اسلام اباد
تاكيدا لدعوه الحزب الذي يطالب بانتخابات
عامه مبكرا
اموت رئيس الوزراء السابق اللثام خلال
كلمه امام انصاره في اول ظهور علني له منذ
محاوله اغتياله في الثالث من هذا الشهر في
مسيره مماثله عن ضغوط جديده على اتلاف
شباب شريف الحاكم اعلن حل الحكومتين
المحليتين في اقليم خيبر والفنجان
واستقالته بحزبه من البرلمانيين المحليين
[موسيقى]
انسحابه من كل البرلمانات المحليه في
الاقاليم وسنعقد لاحقا اجتماعا لتحديد
موعد استقاله وبناء من تلك البرلمانات اذ
لا نريد ان نكون جزءا من النظام الحالي
الفاسد
عامه مبكرا يقول ان لديه الاغلبيه التي
تاهله للعوده لرئاسه الوزراء مجددا ومن
فكت الحكومه تتمسك بموعد اكتوبر القادم
المتفق عليه اصلا
الله تجمع اليوم بلا فائده حتى قبل ان
يبدا
الثابت ان الازمه السياسيه الباكستانيه
تزداد تفاقما منذ تعرض عمران خان في
الثالث من هذا الشهر لمحاوله اغتيال فاشله
في مدينه وزير اباد خلال مسيره احتجاجيه
نظمها خان وحزبه للضغط على حكومه شريف في
ذاته مساعي لذهاب الحكومه الراكنه
ويعتقد كثيرون ان من اسباب تمسك الحكومه
بموعد الانتخابات في اكتوبر القادم وفشل
دعوات خانا المتكرره بتبكير الموعد تعمق
الخلاف بينه وبين الجيش ودابه على اتهام
المؤسسه العسكريه بشكل مباشر بمحاوله
التخلص منه وهو ما شكل براي كثيرين حاضنه
عسكريه ولو بطريقه غير مباشره للائتلاف
الحكومي الراهن
[تصفيق]
هو فصل اخر من فصول الازمه السياسيه
الباكستانيه المعقده التي بدات فصولها منذ
اطاحه البرلمان في ابريل الماضي بحكومه
عمران خان بحجم الثقه عنها بعد انشقاق بعض
شركائه من التحالف